the dragons of Game of Thrones then and
now three of the most powerful forces in
the world of Game of Thrones are Dany's
dragons drogon rhaegal and Viserion over
the past six seasons they have grown
from the size of small castes to 80 foot
Giants before the time of Game of
Thrones dragons had been extinct for
hundreds of years the Valyrians rode
dragons and used them to conquer ss
5,000 years before Daenerys Targaryen
olive alaria was wiped out with a
cataclysmic volcanic eruption 400 years
before the events of Game of Thrones the
only surviving noble family were the
Targaryen who conquered Westeros with
the three remaining dragons when these
dragons died the species was believed to
be extinct leaving behind only their
skeletons decorate the red piece and
petrified eggs
Danny received a gift of three petrified
X at her wedding in season one they
hatched when she brought them into the
funeral pyre of Khal Drogo Danny is
known from that moment forward as the
mother of dragons when the dragons are
born they are about the size of a small
cat Danny discovers that they only eat
cooked meat in season two she teaches
them the command her chorus the Valyrian
word for fire they respond to this
command to kill Pyat pree and free
themselves and their mother from the
house of the undying we see them fly in
season 3 when the dragons arrive with
Danny and flavors say she tricks the
slave master of a stupor into giving her
command of the unsullied in exchange for
her dragon drogon he burns the master
alive revealing a fierce allegiance to
Danny this is further shown when the
Ambassador from yoon kye threatens Danny
in the beginning of season four we
learned that even Danny cannot
completely control these magical
creatures they become more independent
and drogon starts burning the
countryside in search of food
accidentally killing a child Danny is
forced to log rhaegal and Viserion in
the Great Pyramid of murine to protect
her people
dragon is nowhere to be found dragons
never stop growing
but enclosed spaces can hinder their
growth this is why ragle and Viserion
are smaller than dragon because they are
kept underground for almost two years in
season five Danny
allows this area and ragle to burn and
devour a great master when the sons of
the harpy murder Barristan Selmy drogon
comes to his mother's aid when the sons
of the harpy tried to assassinate her it
is at this point that Danny is finally
able to ride the 40-foot long dragon in
season six
Tyrion releases vissarion and ragel from
their chains because they are not eating
this is really interesting because
nobody else has been able to get close
to the Dragons success Danny is Tyrion
secretly a Targaryen also drogon doubles
in size in season six which we see when
Danny rallies the Dothraki behind her to
sail to Westeros making him about 80
feet long in the episode battle of the
bastards
drogon Lance aside Danny so that she can
ride him and his father's break out of
the Great Pyramid to burn the ships of
the great masters we see them last
flying with Danny's fleet to Westeros it
has been revealed by director Matt
Jackman the Dragons will be the size of
747 in season seven they will certainly
be a force in the upcoming battle
between the living and the dead you want
to hear more about the history of
dragons in Westeros and Essos let us
know in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe